okay let's go next to our caller from
the 7/7 for area code who is calling
today from 774 hey it's cliff from
what's there hey cliff what's up cliff
you're breaking up let's back it up for
a second you're breaking up and I'm
crazy ambient noise so let's see if we
can do something about that and I would
love to hear your question cliff hey um
sorry is it better now
it's it's drastically better okay that's
great to hear
um so I've been looking at the news I
heard Bernie just dropped out of the
race I'm just wondering you know
cliff are you communicating in Morse
code no I am not okay because for the
last seconds I heard nothing other than
a Morse code like vibration oh my meters
you wondering about burning Mia
oh no I well actually it's not about
burning I was learning what your stance
is on croquet the lawn game I'm very
much in favor of it oh my god alright
cliff we're gonna see you later
could you imagine a worse connection
than some of these callers that we have
I mean it is under it's where our isn't
everybody at home like how are people
having bad connections I guess unless
they live somewhere with a bad
connection today's program is made
possible in part by our sponsor identity
guard giving my audience 33% off when
you use the link underneath this video
we talk about data breaches on the show
we talk about them too often because
they happen too often and a lot of
people underestimate how likely they are
to become victims of identity theft as a
result of these breaches that take place
and it's a nightmare the average
identity theft victim loses more than
thirteen hundred dollars and six months
of their life
trying to clean the mess up it's no joke
but what identity guard does is monitor
the dark web and alert you any time your
social security number credit card
numbers account numbers or other
personal information are detected in
places where criminals share this stuff
with each other online they also detect
red flags like changes to your bank
accounts or your credit score's and
you'll get an alert as quickly as in a
few seconds if you do become a victim of
identity theft identity guard sets you
up with a dedicated support team who
will take what would normally be a very
stressful situation and turn it into
something as easy as possible to resolve
and you'll be covered for up to a
million dollars of reimbursement for
stolen funds identity guard plans start
at just $8.99 a month but the David
Pakman show audience will instantly get
33% off by using the link underneath
this video you'll also get access to
identity guards browser extension which
protects you from phishing attempts
unsecured websites other types of
attacks just while you're browsing
around online it takes just a few
minutes to set up an account you give
them a few pieces of info about yourself
and you're good to go
the identity theft headaches are often
completely avoidable if you have a
service that's protecting you from it
and will help you to deal with it if
something were to happen an identity
guard is the most trusted one out there
it's already affordable but you'll save
an extra 33 percent when you use my link
which I've put in the description right
underneath this video